That ends the, the,
the basic discussion about.
It was actually done for stereo reasons
which is kind of funny because in stereo
you know that points have to
move along the epipolar line.
Whereas in motion they can move
however they happen to move.
But it was originally derived
in a stereo formulation.
It's actually used a lot more now in
the whole process of, of doing motion.
To actually make work, you, you're going
to have to do things hierarchically,
that is, you are going to do
things at a core scale and
then get to a finer scale and
a finer scale.
And, it's a really good example of doing
multiscale processing on images, and
that's actually why we're
going to do it next time